loser
diego
soviets attack us
this can't be right we're gonna get you
out of here keep your head down
what the hell did we do now
[Music]
hold on
son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
those are nukes old-timers
what about my family you can't save them
if you're dead
[Music]
what was that the end of the world
november 25th 1963.
and where am i now dallas ten days
earlier
i needed to find my family
[Music]
all right quick rundown luther super
strength klaus can come in with the dead
allison can rumor anyone to do anything
except she never uses it
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new umbrella academy
video they're dropping the season this
friday they just dropped the opening
scene from season two episode one
obviously things have gone completely
crazy there's a bunch of easter eggs so
we'll break it down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite umbrella academy moment on the
video
so we'll just go through this footage
shot by shot then i'll talk about the
rest of the season
so they've just failed to stop the end
of the world in the final scene from
season one
and five was trying to send them back in
time to their younger bodies
so that they could just hit the reset
button and call a do-over on trying to
save the world
because that's the whole thing is they
failed in their mission during season
one
this giant asteroid is the moon breaks
apart because of vania's powers as it
comes crashing down to earth just
destroying everything in this giant
blast
you can make all the jokes about
self-fulfilling prophecies that you want
because it was actually them trying to
stop vania that caused her to misfire
and hit the moon that then destroyed the
earth so it seems like something like
that might also be happening with season
two in this giant nuclear blast that
annihilates the world
but you have to remember that this is
literally just the opening moments
right after they've jumped back in time
so they all just wind up
showing up in 1963 not understanding
what's gone wrong
in the middle of this giant war so
instead of merging their consciousnesses
with their younger selves they wind up
in 1960s dallas texas just
days after president kennedy has been
assassinated and the soviets have
apparently invaded
then a nuclear bomb just goes off nearby
heralding the end of the world again
but it's all literally happening in the
span of the first three minutes of the
episode so that's why everyone's so
confused about what's going on like five
says wait a minute what do we do now
what the hell
even diego yells at number five what the
hell did you do now
because number five spent all of season
one causing all kinds of new problems
with his
unreliable time travel ability never
quite working
exactly how he expected the person that
walks up to five and gives him the
terminator speech come with me if you
want to live
is hazel from season one cha-cha's
partner who apparently survived the end
of the world
he works for the commission and just
like in season one the commission
is still very much the villain or the
antagonist of season two
that's who these people are chasing them
all over the trailer
fun easter egg 2 as number 5 exits this
alleyway into the big fire fight
the movie that's playing at this theater
is kiss of the vampire
it is a real movie that was playing in a
theater at this time it's historically
accurate
but it's also a subtle easter egg for
the upcoming umbrella academy comic book
called
you look like death which is about klaus
when he was 18
right after getting kicked out of the
umbrella academy the basic premise of
the comic book is that he heads to
hollywood and runs afoul of a vampire
drug lord
so yes vampires in the world of umbrella
academy
the paper that number five picks up and
reads says that jfk has declared war in
the soviet union i can't read the date
on the newspaper so i don't know if it's
from before jfk was assassinated or
after so it's not clear if this is a lie
that the government just perpetrated and
they declared war after jfk was
assassinated and blamed the soviets for
his death and that's why they declared
war
or if some crazy time travel problem
happened before
they cause jfk to declare war on them
himself
and then he gets killed in retaliation
it's all about time travel and alternate
history
and they're changing the comic book
story from the dallas ark so it's going
to be a little bit different
but the kennedy assassination is very
much the stage
for the plot of season two it's all
about trying to prevent this great
disaster
against the backdrop of jfk being
assassinated in dallas
but remember the whole thing about
self-fulfilling prophecies during season
one they were trying to prevent the end
of the world but their actions directly
led
to the end of the world vanya still
wound up accidentally quote unquote
destroying the world
and while this is all playing you have
that frank sinatra song the recording of
my way it's meant to be a clever wink at
the umbrella academy
team saving the world their way not
necessarily the correct way
probably causing as many problems as
they try to solve the song itself is
also a bit of an easter egg it's meant
to be period specific because it was
recorded during the 1960s and frank
sinatra was in his prime
during the 60s so this is all taking
place during the 1960s so it is period
specific
but he didn't record the song till 1969
and this is all taking place during
1963. so it's a cool song we'll call it
close enough
all this footage is also meant to show
off their abilities in really cool ways
too because it's been about two years
since we saw the last season it's been a
hot minute since we got season one
vanya is floating in the air in the path
of the giant round from the tank fire
she uses her sonic powers to destroy it
just reminding you how powerful she is
and that she still has all of her
abilities in the comic book when this is
all going on
she actually had amnesia for most of
this storyline the way that ellen page
explained it though
is that vanya during season two is still
mostly dealing with all the trauma of
her repressed memories that she had just
gotten back at the end of season one so
i don't think they're
doing any of the crazy amnesia plot
klaus
channels the ghosts of a bunch of
recently killed u.s soldiers from the
last couple of minutes to attack the
soviets
luther just hulks out on all them and
then soaks a bunch of fire damage like
it's no big deal
they upgraded a lot of the visual
effects for his body too that's why he's
not walking around in the trench coat
anymore
that's an easy way for productions like
this to save money like oh we don't have
to render this in cg if he just puts a
giant coat on
ben uses his tentacles to attack more
soldiers the weird thing here is that it
doesn't seem like klaus is actually
channeling his abilities like ben is
doing this on his own up on top of the
building
and how is that possible if he's just a
ghost lots of questions being raised
you also see him opening a door by
himself in the trailer like opening this
car door without klaus doing it for him
there was some confusion about that too
people are like wait a minute is ben
come back to life
but then they make the joke about ghosts
not being able to time travel
so maybe that has something to do with
it but the other members of the umbrella
academy in this scene
when ben is sitting in the background
they can't see him so it seems like he's
still a ghost
allison uses her rumor powers to
literally blow the minds of a bunch of
soldiers like literally exploding their
minds
showing you how powerful her abilities
are diego dodges a
ton of bullets quicksilver style then
takes down the soldiers before yelling
at number five
then as they're all coming together
slowly converging to get their bearings
hazel shows up from season one gives
number five the business
like we're all dead unless we both you
can't save your friends here in this
moment then they jump back into the time
stream while the rest of the group
watches
as the nuclear bomb goes off poof end of
the world
so it's a great opening scene that sets
the stakes for the season and lets you
know what their
endgame is make all the marvel avengers
endgame jokes you want
perfectly balanced as all memes should
be then just because this is the opening
scene there's a lot of stuff that you
don't see in here like them going to the
younger version of reginald hargreaves
and literally telling him his future
with the umbrella academy adopting them
so that he can wind up adopting them in
the future specifically so that they can
become a team and then come back in time
themselves
self-fulfilling prophecy to save the
world you see a little bit of baby pogo
during the trailer too they were making
a lot of jokes on the netflix
social accounts about this because you
have baby yoda on the mandalorian one of
the cutest things on television last
year but now they also have baby pogo on
netflix so you can just decide who you
think is cuter baby pogo versus baby
yoda
speaking of which there is supposed to
be a mandalorian season 2 trailer
sometime in the next couple of weeks so
as soon as they release that of course
i'll do a video for it i'll be doing
episode videos for all the mandalorian
season 2 episodes
while you wait for everything click here
to re-watch that umbrella academy season
trailer and you can click here for that
brand new marvel hellstrom
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you